♪
(Daniel)
We're really excited
about this study that
we just completed
in which we were
for the first time
able to track single neurons
as they're kind of being placed
within the brain.
The field has known
for many years
that these neurons
are very precisely placed,
but how that precise placement
happens
is not really well understood.
We were able to collaborate
with physicists
to develop these microscopes
that enabled very gentle
imaging throughout development
to be able
to capture those early events.
And let me show you
how these videos look.
We can see early
on the first neurons appearing
and the neurons growing out into
what will be the brain.
And then we were able to label
single cells and understand
how is the cell
selecting its placement.
And then it was through
a process that we called
Retrograde Zippering,
It's like it looks very much
like zippering backwards,
you know, the way that you close
a jean for example.
Here we're seeing this blue
neuron
and it's going to zipper
backwards starting at that point
where that green arrow is,
as to meet that other pink
neuron that is in the correct
neighborhood.
You can see it actually closing
the gap, that black space
there as it's now meeting
the correct neighborhood.
This is very important.
What we're able to do with this
microscope is track
those events as they're actually
occurring and ascribe specific
genetic functions
to these molecules
that we're identifying
in that sequence of events.
If your car breaks down,
the reason
that a mechanic can actually fix
the car
is because
there was an engineer
that built the car
and they understand
how the car works.
So over here we have a system
that we didn't build.
We cannot ask the engineer.
So we have to reverse engineer
how it works
to be able to understand
first how it functions
and then how it functions
incorrectly.
Which has implications
to diseases such as autism,
neurodevelopmental disorders,
mental retardation, etc.
But it's a fundamental question
that we need to understand
if we have an aspiration
to be able to understand
how these circuits form
and how they form incorrectly
in early developmental diseases.
♪♪